FAILED AT DOING.
LAFUGH
LAUGH
(LAUGHTER)
.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> DAN KILDEE, THE CHIEF WHIP.
AND WE GOT NEWS IN THE THIRD
QUARTER, THE ECONOMY ZOOMED
AHEAD 33 PLUS PERCENT, IT FELL
IN THE SECOND QUARTER,
NEVERTHELESS, THE COMEBACK
APPEARS TO BE REAL.
STEVE MOORE, WHAT DO YOU MAKE
FIRST OFF OF THE TALK OF
ELIZABETH WARREN AS A TREASURY
SECRETARY IN A BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION?
>> WELL, I THINK IT’S AN
INDICATION OF JUST HOW LEFT
WING A BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
WOULD BE.
ELIZABETH WARREN IS VERY
HOSTILE TO BUSINESS INTERESTS
IN AMERICA.
I THINK SHE WOULD BE TERRIBLE
FOR THE STOCK MARKET, BUT I
THINK A MORE IMPORTANT POINT,
NEIL, WHAT YOU JUST SAID.
MY GOODNESS, YOU AND I HAVE
BEEN IN THIS BUSINESS A LONG
TIME FOLLOWING THESE ECONOMIC
STATISTICS.
CAN YOU THINK AFTER STRONGER
CLOSING STATEMENT FOR DONALD
TRUMP THAN THOSE NUMBERS THAT
CAME OUT ON THURSDAY?
YOU KNOW, 33% GROWTH.
MOST PEOPLE DON’T FOLLOW THIS
STUFF AS CLOSELY AS YOU AND I
DO.
USUALLY 3, 4, 5% GROWTH IS
CONSIDERED A GOOD NUMBER AND WE
GOT THIS 33% GROWTH.
DON’T FORGET, ALSO, NEIL, ON
THURSDAY MORNING, YOU KNOW,
REAL GOOD NUMBERS ON THE
UNEMPLOYMENT WITH ANOTHER BIG
DROP IN THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE ON
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE CLAIMS.
WE’VE HAD SOMETHING LIKE 11.5
MILLION JOBS CREATED SINCE
JUNE.
SO, THOSE ARE--
THAT’S A VERY STRONG NUMBER.
IF I WERE TRUMP I’D SAY LOOK,
WE’RE RIDING ON THE BACK OF
SECRETARIAT HERE RIGHT NOW.
YOU DON’T WANT TO CHANGE
HORSES.
NEIL: BUT YOU KNOW, THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE--
I GUESS IT DEPENDS ON THEIR
VIEW OF THE HORSES BECAUSE 22.7
BILLION AMERICANS ARE STILL
CLAIMING SOME SORT OF
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFIT, AS YOU
KNOW, STEVE.
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
NEIL: A GOOD MANY OF THEM,
MAYBE CLOSE TO A THIRD ARE
EXHAUSTING THOSE BENEFITS.
THEY’LL RUN OUT IN A MATTER OF
WEEKS.
SO FOR THOSE PEOPLE, THAT
DOESN’T SOUND LIKE ROUNDING THE
BEND.
THAT DOESN’T SOUND LIKE AN
ECONOMY ON FIRE.
I’M WONDERING WHEN THE
PRESIDENT POUNDS THAT THEME IN
BATTLE GROUND STATES, I’M SURE
THAT’S THE PRESIDENT FOR YOU
NOW, BUT DOES IT FALL ON EMPTY
EARS?
DO THE PEOPLE HEAR THAT AND SAY
JUST LIKE WHEN HE SAYS THAT
WE’RE ROUNDING THE BEND ON
COVID.
WE’RE NOT.
AND WHEN EVERYTHING IS
HUNKY-DORY ON THE ECONOMY, IT’S
NOT.
>> CERTAINLY I’M NOT SAYING,
AND DONALD TRUMP IS NOT SAYING
EVERYTHING IS HUNKY-DORY WITH
THE ECONOMY, IT’S JUST THIS IS
THE FASTEST RECOVERY WE’VE EVER
SEEN IN THIS COUNTRY AND BY THE
WAY MUCH FASTER THAN ANY OTHER
EUROPEAN COUNTRY.
YOU LOOK AT PROJECTIONS, NEIL,
THAT THE FEDERAL RESERVE BANK
MADE AND THEY SAID LUCKY 12,
13% GROWTH AND HERE WE ARE AT
33% GROWTH.
THEY SAID WE’D PROBABLY STILL
HAVE 15, 16% UNEMPLOYMENT RATE.
WE’RE NOW DOWN BELOW 8%, OF
COURSE YOU’RE RIGHT, THERE ARE
STILL A LOT OF PROBLEMS IN THIS
COUNTRY, HEAVY LIFTING TO DO TO
FIX THE ECONOMY.
THE REAL QUESTION FOR VOTERS,
WHO DO YOU ACTUALLY THINK COULD
DO A BETTER JOB GETTING 10
MILLION JOBS BACK THAT WE STILL
HAVEN’T RECEIVED?
NOBODY EXPECTED THIS KIND OF
BOOM THAT WE’VE SEEN IN TERMS
OF RECOVERY.
IT REALLY IS PRETTY SPECTACULAR
AND BY THE WAY, LOOK AT
MANUFACTURING, LOOK AT THE
CONSTRUCTION.
YOU COVER IT EVERY DAY ON YOUR
SHOW, NEIL.
LOOK WHAT’S HAPPENING WITH THE
HOUSING MARKET.
THOSE ARE REALLY STRONG MARKETS
RIGHT NOW.
NEIL: YOU KNOW, THE MARKET HAD
A ROUGH WEEK, HAD A ROUGH
MONTH, THE SECOND DOWN MONTH.
ONE OF THE WORST WEEKS BEFORE
AN ELECTION WE’VE EXPERIENCED.
NORMALLY NOT GOOD FOR THE PARTY
IN POWER.
ARE YOU WORRIED FOR THE
PRESIDENT?
>> YOU MEAN IN TERMS OF THE
STOCK MARKET OR--
>> YEAH.
>> WELL, LOOK, I THINK THE
STOCK MARKETS IS WEAK BECAUSE
OF WHAT YOU JUST SAID THAT
WE’VE SEEN INCREASING COVID
CASES, BUT YOU KNOW, I THINK
THAT WE’RE SEEING BETTER
TREATMENTS, WE’RE SEEING, YOU
KNOW, PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING
HOSPITALIZED ARE ACTUALLY NOT
GETTING--
THE DEATH RATE IS FALLING.
SO OF COURSE, THIS IS TWO
ISSUES I THINK AT THE TOP OF
MIND OF VOTERS.
NUMBER ONE, WHO CAN GET US
THROUGH THIS, YOU KNOW,
TERRIBLE ECONOMIC TIME AND I
THINK, YOU KNOW, MOST VOTERS
AGREE IT’S PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THERE’S AN IF HE WHO IS GOING
TO DEAL WITH THIS HEALTH CRISIS
AND WE HAVE PARALLEL CONCERNS.
I THINK IT WAS BILL CLINTON
SAID IT’S THE ECONOMY STUPID.
IF IT’S THE ECONOMY, THEN I
THINK THAT TRUMP IS GOING TO
WIN IN STATES LIKE MICHIGAN AND
PENNSYLVANIA.
ONE LAST THING, WHERE THE
RECOVERY HAS BEEN, NEIL, IT’S
BEEN IN THE SOUTHERN STATES, IN
TEXAS, TENNESSEE, IT’S IN
FLORIDA, IT’S IN STATES LIKE